[Música]
bien para hablarles de mi pasión que es
una pasión compartida con un equipo
multidisciplinario muy amplio desde hace
varios años en relación con la eco
creación en ese sentido nosotros venimos
trabajando un equipo que constituimos a
través de una cooperativa para tratar de
abordar el tema que nos apasiona que nos
roba el sueño que no importa lo de las
horas de trabajo que se invierta que no
es otro que la dignidad del ser humano
entendiendo como ser humano una persona
multidimensional o sea una persona que
tiene múltiples dimensiones entre ellas
la biológica la sociológica la
psicológica espiritual jurídica ética
pero también una dimensión ecológica en
ese sentido desde él desde hace tiempo
más o menos de 1996 para acá con fuerza
nos venimos ocupando de que va haciendo
la gente en el convivir con los otros
porque nosotros pensamos que la gente es
creadora de su realidad que puede crear
la realidad la que va viviendo pero
juntos también podemos crear contexto de
bienestar con equidad también nos
ocupamos de que va siendo la gente en el
convivir con los otros porque las
personas somos la infinita posibilidad
de hacer lo que queramos ser nosotros
podemos entonces crearlo nosotros mismos
pero podemos crear la realidad ahora
bien cualquiera de nosotros voy a
preguntarse pero si somos tan creadores
porque yo no tengo la calle que yo
quiero yo quiero una calle que tenga
muchos árboles
yo quiero caminar por una calle con
árboles frondosos que me den sombra que
me refresque en mi caminar y que me den
con su verde un paisaje hermoso porque
yo no tengo en la calle que yo quiero en
ese sentido nosotros nos hemos dado
cuenta que el mundo está cambiando
aceleradamente y que la biosfera está
dando unas señales evidentes signos
evidentes de que nosotros también
debemos transformarnos y debemos
entonces en esa transformación
adaptarnos a un nuevo estilo de vida un
estilo de vida que sea más sencillo que
sea más simple
se parezca más a la forma como se
organiza la naturaleza para vivir de esa
manera más simple podemos nosotros
alfabetizar nos ecológicamente y esa
ecoalf a betis acción implica que
conozcamos en la manera natural como lo
hace la naturaleza a través de seis
sencillos principios de la ecología
profunda esos principios son los
relacionados con las redes que implica
que los sistemas vivos están dentro de
otros sistemas vivos que hay redes
dentro de redes y que esos sistemas
vivos están comunicándose solidariamente
y compartiendo recursos continuamente
tiene que ver con el tema de los ciclos
los ciclos son muy importantes para
nosotros como seres vivos porque
necesitamos alimentarnos de los flujos
de materia y energía y reciclar los
residuos de esos procesos para volverlos
a convertir en materia y energía un
ciclo muy importante por ejemplo es el
ciclo del agua nosotros este necesitamos
el agua no solamente para preparar
alimentos para calmar la sed o para
asearnos nosotros sabemos por la
reciente
estuvimos con la energía en venezuela
cuban importantes y el agua por ejemplo
para poder tener la energía eléctrica
que nos permite usar la computadora el
el ascensor
la lavadora la nevera y cuanto confort
podemos recibir nosotros gracias a esa
fuente de energía primaria otro de los
aspectos que tenemos que tomar en cuenta
es la energía pero la energía del sol
que es la gran fuerza que mueve todos
los ciclos vitales es una energía que
nosotros podemos conocer mejor y podemos
utilizar este de una manera más
productiva solo tenemos que darnos la
oportunidad de comprender cómo funciona
tenemos también el tema de la asociación
y esto es muy importante porque en la
medida que cooperamos y baa establecemos
redes de asociación y de confianza esas
mismas redes se hacen más fuertes se
hacen más poderosas también e implica
que tengamos en cuenta la diversidad
mientras más biodiversidad hay en un
sistema mientras más incluyente seamos
también somos más fuertes en red es
decir no podemos dejar que nada
que era excluido tenemos que incluirlos
a todos a toda persona sin importar su
conocimiento sin importar su edad sin
importar su género todos podemos ser
incluidos y la última se refiere al
equilibrio dinámico y esto el equilibrio
dinámico es muy importante porque
implica que nosotros asumamos actitudes
que nos permitan fluir con flexibilidad
buscando en nuestras ser no los niveles
máximos de productividad sino tratando
de alcanzar los niveles óptimos es decir
aquellos niveles de productividad que no
dañan la biosfera que no afectan nuestra
salud y que por el contrario protegen a
la naturaleza y protegen nuestra salud
en este sentido es importante entonces
que comprendamos que la alfabetización
no es una cuestión de teoría es algo que
tiene que ser aplicado mediante el
ecodiseño en nuestra vida cotidiana de
manera que nosotros podamos comportarnos
con tres prestando tres servicios
ecosistémicos esos servicios
ecosistémicos éste se pueden prestar en
la vida cotidiana y tienen que ver con
la regulación del clima la regeneración
de la atmósfera y tiene que ver con el
procesado de los residuos es algo así
como cuando yo tengo en mi calle el
árbol el grupo de árboles que me
permiten a mí caminar pero la medida que
voy caminando toma conciencia de que esa
masa verde de árboles en el transitar
por la calle está cumpliendo la función
de regular el clima porque con su sombra
genera una temperatura menor me está
ayudando a la regeneración de la
atmósfera porque está absorbiendo co2 y
al mismo tiempo está emitiendo oxígeno y
además de eso ayuda con el procesado de
residuos porque los árboles con sus
hojas nos
a limpiar la atmósfera y el aire
recogiendo el polvo entonces cómo
podemos nosotros comportarnos de una
manera más verde más natural como hace
el árbol o como hacen los otros sistemas
de la naturaleza de eso se trata el
ecodiseño
ahora bien el ecodiseño puede ser
aplicado en todos los ámbitos de nuestra
vida puede ser aplicado en la economía
en la familia en la comunidad puede ser
aplicado inclusive en la política en la
empresa en esos ámbitos podemos nosotros
aplicar el ecodiseño y por supuesto uno
de los más importantes es el ámbito de
la educación
nosotros podemos convencer a los
miembros de nuestra familia para que
cambien la manera de comportar
comportarse y tomemos conciencia de la
huella ecológica que vamos dejando con
nuestras actividades todos los días pero
al mismo tiempo podemos incidir en los
políticos en los empresarios las
empresarias los maestros y las maestras
para que cambiemos la forma de educar
cambiemos la forma de legislar cambiemos
la forma de gerenciar y de emprender en
nuestras empresas
aquí por ejemplo nosotros vemos un
trabajo que representa algo así parecido
a un trabajo de un kinder hecho por un
niño resulta que esto es un trabajo muy
lúdico que representa un jardín
depurativo que es una tecnología
profunda que desarrollan ingenieros
químicos en el estudio que hacen de las
aguas cuando éstas presentan este el
estado de aguas grises o aguas que
tienen que ser procesadas porque no son
aptas para el riego para el consumo
humano y es un jardín depurativo que fue
diseñado y elaborado en un taller lúdico
donde se aplican las estrategias de cual
favetti secciones o diseños por
comunidades muy pobres que viven bajo la
línea de pobreza crítica y extrema que
tienen serios problemas de acceso al
agua potable y que han tenido la
oportunidad de comprender como
utilizando elementos naturales como
plantas piedras y elementos de diseño
este para poder potabilizar el agua en
un 90% un 98 por ciento que si bien no
queda totalmente apta para el consumo
humano si puede ser utilizada para el
riego
entonces fíjense ustedes como la
aplicación de la alfabetización
ecológica de los principios de la
ecología no tiene que ser algo complejo
ni difícil es algo que todos podemos
aprender de una manera lúdica y muy
sencilla como lo harían unos niños en un
kinder
esto nos permite nosotros entonces que
permite que nuestras familias y nuestras
comunidades puedan gozar de una salud
integral esa salud que tiene que ver con
el cuerpo con la mente con el espíritu
permite también que lo hagamos para
convivir con equidad de género y con
inclusión incluyendo aún a las personas
que tengan capacidades diferentes
personas que tengan una capacidad esté
distinta a las nuestras
esto permite también que éste podamos
nosotros vivir la plenitud de la
dignidad humana porque nadie queda
afuera y todo el mundo puede gozar
entonces de una salud integral y de un
contexto de bienestar en ese estilo de
vida aquí por ejemplo ustedes ven gente
que están haciendo un análisis de la
matriz biológica que representa la isla
de margarita es un equipo de personas
que están trabajando desde las
comunidades analizando los diferentes
barrios y ríos y urbanizaciones de la
isla de margarita esté haciendo su
diagnóstico comunitario desde uno de
ccoo inspirador para aplicar los
principios de la ecología profunda
entonces como ustedes pueden ver
y adultos niños jóvenes personas
inclusive estaban en el taller con
capacidades distintas que estaban todos
interactuando de una manera lúdica y
recreativa aprendiendo cómo pueden
cambiar la mirada para transformar
compasión y amor es esa realidad a la
que se están moviendo
esta es realmente nuestra pasión de
poder transmitirle a personas de escasos
recursos a personas que de repente están
excluidas el sistema muchos de ellos que
no saben porque muchas veces leer y
escribir la posibilidad de poder eco
diseñar su vivienda de ccoo diseñar su
barrio su urbanización de poder cambiar
el estilo de vida de poder éste
desempeñarse de una manera más
sostenible y armónica con la naturaleza
esto es algo que está en la oportunidad
que ellos han vislumbrado de que sin ir
a la universidad inclusive pueden ser
arquitectos por un día
fíjense aquí está una maqueta de un
urbanismo desarrollado por ellos mismos
que por supuesto luego los arquitectos y
los urbanistas llevan a su formato
electrónico y que permite expresar todos
los elementos de diseño que ellos
incorporan a lo largo de los talleres
cada uno de nosotros pudiéramos mirar de
nuevo nuestra casa mirar nuestra calle y
entonces poder caminar por esas calles
llenas de árboles para que nuestro
caminar
he refrescado por la sombra este al
mismo tiempo con un aire limpio y que
permita que nosotros además aprovechemos
el paisaje con ese verdor que se puede
tener cuando creamos esos bosques de
galería para el tránsito la producción
pero también para la distracción y el
relax
esa es la de nuestra pasión nosotros
creemos que es una metodología sumamente
accesible para cualquier persona en eso
este nosotros nos estamos esforzando en
aportar al mundo una nueva manera de
hacer las cosas de hacerla con sentido
ecológico de proteger el medio ambiente
y de contribuir de manera directa a
revertir el proceso de desgaste que
tiene la matriz biológica que nosotros
tenemos para vivir que nos nutrimos
sostiene cómo es el planeta tierra yo
por lo menos me siento feliz como mamá y
ahora como abuela ya que creo dos
generaciones después de mí de poder
decirle a los ojos a mi hija ya mi nieta
yo sí estoy haciendo algo todo depende
de qué querer yo quiero tú quieres
ustedes quieren muchas gracias
[Aplausos]